introducing Constitution 101 the
national Constitution Center and KH
Academy are teaming up to offer students
a free online course on the US
Constitution led by conversations hosted
by Jeffrey Rosen president and CEO of
the national Constitution Center and sou
con founder and CEO of KH Academy joined
by dozens of constitutional Scholars
professors and experts from diverse
political philosophies students will
explore the Constitution historical
foundations Landmark Supreme Court cases
and contemporary constitutional issues
pioneered by the founders and diverse
figures from across American history the
semester-long course will provide
nonpartisan constitutional education to
counter the Civics crisis facing America
where Civics achievement is at the same
level as 1998 students will gain
knowledge to becom engage citizens and
Foster an understanding of diverse
viewpoints all of the videos quizzes and
exercises will be designed to align with
State curriculum standards Nationwide
it's all on KH Academy and as always
it's free to anyone anywhere KH Academy
and the national Constitution Center
shaping the future of nonpartisan civic
education with Constitution 101
launching September
[Music]